if you're russell wilson you've won a
super bowl you've been to two
what's he played eight or nine years i
think this is year ten and he's watching
is it ten and he's watching pat mahomes
like do whatever he wants
and he's watching tom brady be tom brady
wouldn't you think in a million years
you're thinking to yourself
why aren't they treating me this way
michael irvin don't you think he must be
thinking
why are they questioning me at this
point
yes whose how are you good morning
michael talk to you
oh my god you know
listen there's a lot going on man and
it's football
it's the gift that doesn't stop giving
it doesn't stop we can't get to an
offseason there is no such thing as an
offseason because every week something
is trickling out and that and that's the
thing now sues
that's the thing we understand i said
this years ago when we started these
giving out these contracts and you're
giving this kind of money and guaranteed
money
i said teams have to start making this
adjustment there's no more dominion over
these players
it is partnership with these players and
and you got to sit here and work with
him
russell wilson was going through a bad
spill that's what that article's talking
about
he's going through a bad spill russell
wilson is who we are talking about
why would you not listen to him on how
he feels
you can he can best come out of this
situation that
that that stuff like that blows my mind
when he has to put the football
in his hands to go on the football field
you should always listen anyway because
he feels
what he's coming up with is his best
opportunities
and you're saying to him no we're not
doing that
that's hard to understand i mean things
have changed so much you look at a young
guy like patrick mahomes and they're
basically telling him here are the keys
to the car do as you wish
you're looking at tom brady who can do
no wrong
how much more does russell wilson have
to do michael
for pete carroll to sit back and say
okay
i'm going to let you run this offense
the way you want to run it
i'm going to tell you i i know i know
it's hard for people to understand
because you've been having great success
you're like
why is this coming up with all of this
great success
even all that and rogers is going
through it
and and the little risk that seems to be
just simmering over there now
and all of this but i'm telling you
i saw it first hand i
saw it when we were at the pinnacle
coming on back to back super bowls
these power struggles that come in and
tear
everything up i saw it firsthand
and that's what we're seeing now we're
seeing these are power struggles these
are coaches
that have done great by them on their
own
even before those quarterbacks have
gotten with them and these are
quarterbacks
that are ultimately saying it's
my tail that's on the line every time i
line up or
when russell went through that spell
everybody was talking about russell
wilson
russ wilson it's my tail on the line
did y'all watch it when you don't win a
super bowl as a football player
nobody remembers the gm suzy they only
remember the quarterback
nobody knows who damn marino's gm is
all we say is dan marino didn't win a
super bowl
and those guys are trying to take
control of their legacy
that's just what's happening now because
it's the quarterback out there with the
number on the back i mean he's the one
people he's the reason why
guys are buying jerseys because of the
quarterback and also we also know
russell wilson had a bunch of banged up
running backs so he was out there by
himself
you bring up right susie and susie
there's also only
maybe eight or nine real ones in 32
teams
my degree is [ __ ] business management and
organization
the first thing they teach you in
business is supply and demand baby
supply and demand and if you're in the
top 10
and there's a demand of 32 oh you got
some power
you got some power and we're seeing that
this whole season
susie schuster here on the rich eisen
show sitting in for rich with michael
irvin thanks for calling in again mike
uh let's talk about dak prescott since
you talk about this we're going to go
around the league it looks like with a
quarterback carousel as usual
what is happening in dallas i mean i'm
just so curious about
why didn't jerry jones just resign him
and move on and make him the
establish him as the star that he wants
to be
and guys i i do like sometimes we always
believe that people don't listen to what
is being said outside
and and and how things are changing
a couple years ago susie i i went on
right here in dallas
and went off back then back then
the number the number was 30 million
dollars a year
everybody was complaining like i don't
know what
about paying that prescott 30 million
dollars
a year are you joking like you know
you know how many times i measure man on
distance travel
i mean this is a fourth round pick that
has done what he has done
and you're tr you got those all those
years for free
basically and now you're complaining
about paying them 30 i said i promise
you
the number only goes north from here so
you you
in another year you're going to be
complaining more now that number is
going north seemed like a 40
41 million dollars a year you just got
to bite the bullet and get it done now
now both sides i said jerry you got to
figure it out
and buy the bullet and get it done let
me tell you what my concerns
are with that
and it ties back into what you just
talked about
russell wilson moving around we got our
matthew stafford just moved around you
know we got
top guys that are coming available on a
market or trying to make themselves
available
on the market so we are going to have
some activity
with top guys out of some very good guys
on the market now with all of that
movement at quarterback that we never
used to get
you got to start looking at the value of
the seat that you are sitting
in and the value of the seat that that
prescott is sitting in
is of great value to be the dallas
cowboys quarterback you think russell
wilson would love to be the dallas
cowboys quarterback i know it would take
a lot
a whole lot to do that but i'm telling
you we're getting quality quarterbacks
that are coming available
if i'm that prescott i'm going to tell
my people
hey let's get something done i don't
want to have my chair
in this musical chair game that is
starting to go on
out here and i know he has all the
leverage i'm not talking about the money
i'm talking about the chair he's in i
also wonder michael michael irvin here
on the rich eisen show i'm susie
schuster sitting in for him i'm also
wondering how this affects the chemistry
in the locker room
because if the guys are seeing how dak
prescott's treated
wouldn't they be thinking well how are
they going to treat me
yeah that that that trickles down but
there jerry kind of went backwards in
this because he took care of a lot of
the other guys
prior to taking care of that you know
trying to find see if we can find
a value for that and the market is going
to find the value
for that you know so he took a lot of
other guys you know
so so that may have helped some that was
going that is going on
in the locker room and something we're
talking about different numbers now
you know i i i people always say man
jerry's doing that wrong
stop it there's no such thing as doing
somebody wrong we're talking about
35 40 million dollars a year says just
stop it this is just business
nobody's doing it you know what i said
jerry didn't do that wrong last year
jack made 35 million dollars last year
you know gary i just want to make a
minimum of 38 million dollars
this year there's no doing anybody wrong
in that situation
it's just they have to sit down and find
the deal
and get a deal done wait say that again
how much money was he making
man that was started with 33 million
i just love how you said it are you
kidding me now michael
michael what about what's happening in
houston have you ever seen such a
strange
scenario as what's happening in houston
with deshaun watson
yeah and i still said i said and
you know what and i'm gonna tell you i
thought about that too because i knew
something was coming down when i broke
that
you saw that that deandre hopkins story
uh a little while ago
uh and how bill o'brien and that meeting
went
some of the things that went on and
there and i had heard about all of this
stuff that was going on
in houston then i heard about it all
then
so i waited to see and and you know wait
to see what trickles down and how it
happened
and this happened what i was surprised
about was when deshaun watson signed the
deal
because i knew all these things a lot of
things were going on
and then as i thought about it why why
would he do that why would he do that
but the more i thought about it it was
brilliant that he did it
because the deal that he signed puts the
no trade clause
in the deal now ultimately
he they didn't step up and do things
they won't do now he moves he has to
told he has total control
you can send me where i want to go you
can send me you you'll send me where i
want to go
as opposed to if i didn't sign a deal
you have control over me
because you'll keep franchising tag
franchise tagging me
so so yeah i i i'm shocked that it's
gotten that
bad but but we've seen a lot of things
going on in houston a lot of people
questioned and wondered about
and and desean was the guy that just
bring it to a head and said enough to
nothing that's what they're dealing with
now they have to deal with
there's no more what i call painting
over the rust
you know suzy when i was growing up i
hope they don't come and get me i hope
the statue of limitations have run out
on this but
but when i was still a bicycle because
we didn't have anything i was 15 to 17
kids i was still a bicycle and i'm sorry
kid i stole the bike and i would go run
and in order to not get caught i would
pay it right fast
to put some paint on and every time i
painted it fast
i would paint over some rust a few few
months later the rust come right back i
learned that you got to sand down the
rust first
before you paint it all the rust will
come right back
and houston now is in the sanding down
process
no more just paint over this rust
because what desean watson
ain't going for it we gotta sand it down
and then get it out of here
this is this is like home uh home ed
with michael irvin
on the rich eisen show you never know
what you're gonna get when you tune in
to the rich eisen show
i'm
[Laughter]
half of florida's going to tweet out he
stole my bike
don't joke uh one last question football
related uh what's happening in
indianapolis with
the the jersey gate if you had been
in dallas and troy aikman had said to
you i want 88 we're talking of course
about michael pittman and carson wentz
coming into india and wanting his number
11.
would you have given the 88 off your
back to troy aikman
yeah i i did this part trips me out
let me it's not like okay i'm gonna say
no to the god
right there and then you know i want him
to say yes to me
throw me the ball throw me the ball
throw the ball this this is
that that that blew my mind you saw how
quick god when got off that jersey for
this for tom brady and i know he's a
goat
i know he's the goat but he's just still
this quarterback you get a quarterback
what he wants so the quarterback can
give you what you want
to say you know dude i would be in that
house hey man
he led me remember who gave that to you
come on now let's play let's go you know
what i'm saying i'll be taught that's
what i'd become
i would be calling cause 11. you
remember who gave that to you
can i get you you give me the ball but
that's yesterday i think already leaking
into carson wentz tomorrow i guarantee
that that's
that's those guys hearing about the
locker room situations in philly
and already saying no you look you got
to come and earn this over here we're
not giving you anything
and that's what i think got to say
there's no doubt
that that set the tone for his time in
indy no doubt right
yeah no doubt no no doubt and i know he
can overcome it
he can overcome it but i think what it
does
is it get is give gives him an
understanding of
oh no no no you're not walking over here
as a high-picked quarterback
who gets whatever he wants you got to
come and earn this well i i'm not coming
up with
it that the fact that we're even hearing
about
it that they didn't go to him
and and and you know the organization
and try to smooth
all of this out that we have it here
i i think that says something you know
that that says
they should have gone to them even and
talk the pitman about that once you knew
you were getting cautious over there
before any of the media
got the cars got got to michael pittman
about that stuff
michael thank you for coming on i love
having you on i'll probably have you on
every single time i'm on the air thanks
for having
thanks for coming by today mike dude
absolutely love it susan and when all
this craziness go away
and you come on i'm i'm gonna fly out
there and co-host with you welcome and
hang out
you better you better promise i would
love that i promise you
right now i would absolutely do that
absolutely you know i would do it for
you i know
you're my kid's godfather for christ you
know really i mean
you're her godfather so you got to come
out and do that for me
and that's why i would do it thanks
michael you have a great day
i love you love you too that's michael
irvin on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here